all right as many of you know i am
fascinated by scams and it just so
happens that the former president and
the current republican party have
perpetrated a number of different scams
not only on the american people
generally but on their own followers and
donors we've talked about
fundraising scams before one such scam
was that after the 2020 election donald
trump claimed to be raising money for
fighting the election results for
overturning the election and you could
donate presumably to audits and recounts
and whatever else now that was a scam on
its face obviously because they weren't
going to overturn the election but there
were other layers on which it was a scam
as well for example in the fine print
when trump was raising money to overturn
the election results depending on the
promo you would look at the fine print
and it would say
50 percent of your donation
60 of your donation can be used
not to fighting to overturn the election
but to pay off trump's campaign debt
prior to the election the scam was
some pre-check boxes when you would make
what you thought was a one-time donation
to trump
one of the boxes that was automatically
checked unless you uncheck it
is that you're committing to an ongoing
donation even though you meant to make a
single and the second box was that in
some cases the amount would go up
whatever your donation there would be
like a multiplier of some kind added on
in the subsequent donation so that was
another scam that they did
there's a new scam now or at least it
has returned the new scam is that the
nrsc that's the national republic
republican senatorial committee is
running a promo called
dinner with trump now if i say to you we
are running a have dinner with me promo
would you expect me to be at the dinner
i think so
if i ran a promo called have dinner with
my mom
would you expect my mom to be at the
dinner yes i think so
if uh a celebrity chef
like our friend tyler florence runs a
have dinner with tyler promo would you
expect him to be there
i would
but the dinner with trump dinner
doesn't have trump
this is a huge thing
they're promoting it as enter to win
dinner with trump
do you want to have dinner with
president trump
enter now for your chance to meet
president trump
but then you pull out the fine print
and it says a winner and a guest will
have a private dinner with
senators
lindsey graham
tim scott
and rick scott that there's no mention
of trump
trump won't be at the dinner
for the winner of the dinner with trump
promo or giveaway
um judd legume or legum
has been researching this and apparently
this is a common scam that trump and
republicans ran during the 2020 campaign
there were all these promos lunch with
trump in chicago dinner with trump in
cleveland all of this stuff now is it
possible some of these events happened
and trump had lunch or dinner with
somebody
that won the thing i know he had lunch
or dinner but with some of the people
who actually entered maybe but there is
no evidence that we're able to find that
any of these events actually took place
now i want to be really clear
i don't care about the people getting
scammed here in the sense that
if you're willing willing to do anything
to help trump and these republicans win
donate
whatever for a meal with trump arguably
you've been scammed merely by the
fact that you're supporting this corrupt
party so like missing the dinner
is kind of the cherry on top of the scam
but shouldn't there be repercussions
here because if you run a lottery and
nobody wins you just collect the money
that's illegal when you do giveaways
raffles etc these things are governed by
a bunch of different law
and it's taken pretty seriously in most
cases when you aren't trump i guess or
the national republican senate committee
or whatever it is that they're called
everything is a scam
the campaign itself the promises that
were made but not kept the presidency
itself the fundraising
now even the giveaways are a scam as
well they should be held accountable no
evidence that they are going to be
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video